und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Maria Slomka guten Abend zwei
Stühle am Kabinettstisch hatten schon
immer einen besonders ungemütlichen Sitz
Verteidigungsministerium und
Gesundheitsministerium beides Bereiche
in denen regelmäßig auch ohne Krieg oder
Pandemie großer Reformbedarf
festgestellt wird die Amtsträger und
Trägerinnen sich dann aber an diesen
großen Reformen meist mehr oder weniger
verhoben haben zu komplex die Aufgabe zu
stark die behaarungskräfte
fürs Gesundheitswesen startet Karl
Lauterbach nun einen neuen Versuch der
seine Amtszeit prägen soll eine große
krankenhausreform sie soll im Kern
zurücknehmen was vor zwei Jahrzehnten
als wegweisende reformide
man mit den Hintergrund
diese Bilder sind 20 Jahre alt
Uniklinikum Freiburg Herzchirurgie
damals kam es zu einer ungewöhnlichen
Kooperation die Porsche AG beriet die
Mediziner man muss nur an den richtigen
Schrauben drehen im Fall damals Manager
Wiedeking dann laufe es besser Ökonomie
und Klinik schon nach kurzer Zeit zog
der Autobauer eine bemerkenswerte Bilanz
wir haben die Liegezeiten also die Zeit
die ein Patient im Krankenhaus
verbringen muss von 11,2 Tage auf 9,6
Tage reduzieren können mehr
Produktivität heißt natürlich heute für
die Klinik sie können also 30 % mehr
Kapazität aufnehmen bei gleichen Kosten
nur ein Beispiel von vielen vor 20
Jahren hielt die Ökonomie Einzug in den
Kranken hausalltag mit Fallpauschalen
weg von starren Strukturen und hohen
Kosten oder Schmidt damals
Bundesgesundheitsministerin und Karl
Lauterbach damals Experte und Berater
brachten die Umwälzung auf den Weg zwei
Jahrzehnte später ist das System aus dem
Ruder gelaufen
die Patientin Patienten können nicht
aufgenommen werden oder müssen in weit
entfernte Krankenhäuser verlegt werden
das Krankenhauspersonal ist massiv
überlastet die Regierungskommission hat
extrem ernst genommen das ist lichterloh
brennt das Problem ist halt mindestens
10 Jahren bekannt und es ist bisher nie
grundsätzlich also angegangen worden ist
bekommt die wir jetzt hier in Auftrag
gegeben haben an der wir jetzt Arbeiten
aus meiner Sicht eine Revolution im
System Lauterbach will also jetzt die
Revolution seines irgendwie auch eigenen
Systems das heißt weg von den Preisen
für jede Behandlung hinzu mehr festen
Budgets unabhängig von der Zahl der
behandelten Fälle den Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeitern bietet die Möglichkeit
dass der ökonomische Druck aus dem
System endlich rausgenommen wird aber
noch mal es ist nicht ganz ohne Ökonomie
zu machen weil sonst die Kosten im
Gesundheitssystem explodieren würden
allein von 2005 bis 2021 Namen
vollstationäre Operationen um 31% zu
viele Eingriffe gleich hoher Umsatz auch
unnötige Operationen wurden gemacht aus
Gewinnstreben ein gefährliches
Hamsterrad für Personal und Kranke damit
soll Schluss sein das heißt weniger
Eingriffe und stärkere Spezialisierung
Stichwort Fachkliniken und überhaupt
mehr ambulant statt stationär bei den
Plänen müssen die Länder Magazin danach
sieht es erstmal nicht aus saßen sie
doch selbst gar nicht mit am reformtisch
wissen Sie eine Theorie ist das eine
wissenschaftliche Studien zu bewerten
aber die Dinge dann auf die Straße zu
bringen zu den Menschen zu bringen das
ist das andere und da glaube ich ist
zwischen dem was Karl Lauterbach
manchmal sagt und dem was dann ankommt
schon die Differenz Rebellion gegen
Lauterbachs Revolution die Sorge
Kliniken in ländlichen Gebieten könnten
nicht überleben von Schließungen ist auf
der Pressekonferenz wohl ganz bewusst
nicht die Rede ausgeschlossen sind sie
nicht
der Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine
der Krieg der seitdem dort tobt
überstrahlt ja vieles doch im Schatten
dieser Gefechte gibt es noch einen
anderen Krisenherd mitten in Europa der
für unseren Kontinent sehr gefährlich
werden könnte und bei dem Russland
übrigens auch seine Finger im Spiel hat
nicht zuletzt durch alte Verbindungen
aus Sowjet Zeiten
der westliche Balkan ist eine der
Problemzonen der EU die Perspektive der
EU beizutreten es war geblieben die
alten Konflikte in der Region sind nicht
wirklich gelöst und neben Russland
versucht auch China dort Einfluss zu
gewinnen direkt vor der Haustür der EU
besser gesagt in ihrem Innenhof die EU
hat die Gefahr immerhin erkannt und sich
heute zum Westbalkan Gipfel in Albaniens
Hauptstadt Tirana getroffen
es ist eigentlich ein großer Tag im
Leben des albanischen Regierungschefs eh
die Rama die EU zum ersten Mal zu Gast
doch nicht jeder scheint ihn zu kennen
der schwedische Regierungschef lässt
Drama fast stehen ich bin nicht der
Sicherheitsbeamte klärt er ihn auf ich
bin der albanische Regierungschef und
dann wird die Begrüßung herzlich
die Prachtstraße auf der die
Regierungschefs zum Gipfel fahren ist
geschmückt mit Europas Helden zumindest
aus albanischer Sicht der französische
Philosoph wollte er und die ehemalige
Bundeskanzlerin der Gipfel soll Hoffnung
machen er macht deutlich dass die
Europäische Union den Westbalkan genauso
braucht wie der westbalkant die
Europäische Union nicht jeder spielt bei
der inszenierten Harmonie mit der
serbische Regierungschef Vucic hat enge
Beziehung zu Russlands Präsidenten Putin
Serbien braucht das russische Gas
deshalb unterstützt er auch nicht die
eu-sanktion
wir bleiben Europa freundlich aber wir
müssen auch unseren nationalen
Interessen vertreten
die Präsidentin vom Kosovo zuckt
zusammen wenn Serbiens Regierungschef
von nationalen Interessen spricht denn
Serbien erkennt den Kosovo nicht an der
Konflikt droht zu eskalieren ihre Bitte
um Hilfe geht fast im Hubschrauber
lärmutter
das Verhandlung die die Europäische
Union und die die USA begleiten die
einzige Chance sind um eine Einigung zu
erreichen indem sich beide Länder
anerkennen
die EU-Spitze und das Pulverfass
Westbalkan eine Bedingung für den
Beitritt ist die Gespenster der
Vergangenheit ruhen zu lassen ihr müsst
euch entscheiden auf welcher Seite ihr
steht auf der Seite der Demokratien das
ist die Europäische Union eurer Freunde
und Partner oder wollt ihr einen anderen
Weg wählen
der Gipfel wollte sich locker geben ein
wenig Emotionen zeigen für eine
Beziehung die schwierig ist die
Annäherung zwischen EU und dem
Westbalkan geht schleppend voran seit
Jahren wird der Beitritt versprochen
mangelnde Rechtsstaatlichkeit
grassierende Korruption und Konflikte
unter den Ländern verhindern das
Scholz weiß um die Probleme aber der
Bundeskanzler will seit dem Ukraine
Krieg vor allem den Einfluss Russlands
in der Region zurückdrängen die
Annäherung an den Westbalkan soll
deshalb schneller gehen insofern ist es
wichtig dass jetzt neuer Schwung in
diese Beratung und Diskussion gekommen
ist und dass wir den Beitritt dieser
Länder schnell organisieren
Olaf Scholz geht und sucht weiter nach
Lösungen für Albanien zumindest war der
erste EU-Gipfel im eigenen Land eines
historischer Tag
den west-balkan geostrategisch an die EU
anzubinden ist die eine Seite der
Medaille auf der anderen Seite hat die
Europäische Union jetzt schon erhebliche
Probleme ihrer aktuell 27 Mitglieder
unter einen Hut zu bekommen geschweige
denn die Mitgliedsstaaten auf gemeinsame
Werte zu verpflichten so hat sich
Ungarns Viktor Orban zu einer Art
systemsprenger entwickelt derzeit
versucht er weitere Finanzhilfen für die
Ukraine zu blockieren weniger aus
Sympathien für Moskau die gibt's bei ihm
zwar auch aber hier geht es vor allem um
einen taktisches Manöver wenn ihr mehr
Druck macht blockiere ich euch ein
anderer Stelle und so verlief dann heute
auch das Treffen der EU Finanzminister
in Brüssel von dort berichtet
27 Finanzminister da gibt es wichtige
Gesten und besorgte Blicke und immer
einen der froh sein kann dass er nicht
allein da steht diesmal ist das der
Ungarn
mit dem Glöckchen ist eigentlich Schluss
die Kameras müssen raus diesmal ist das
anders die EU überträgt anschließend
live ihr eigenes Scheitern beim
Tagespunkt Finanzhilfen für die Ukraine
haben Beamte eine Einigung erzielt
eigentlich
sehr gut aber tatsächlich fehlt ein
Mitgliedstaat und sie wissen welcher wir
kommen nicht weiter ich teile den Frust
von ihnen allen
der Vorsitzende fragt nach und Ungarn
bleibt
der Änderung der finanzregeln nicht zu
danke schön
eigentlich wollten alle anderen auch der
deutsche Minister sich gemeinsam mit 18
Milliarden Euro Verschulden für die
Ukraine dass wir nicht unsere
Solidarität auch in finanzieller
Hinsicht ausdrücken können das
verantwortet Ungarn beluffte die wir
unser Versprechen an die Ukraine müssen
wir einlösen und zwar jetzt
die Ukraine ist im Krieg und wäre in der
Pleite ohne die EU-Hilfe ihr Leid diene
als Hebel im Streit zwischen Ungarn und
der EU das ist fake News schreibt aber
heute Ungarn ist bereit der Ukraine
Finanzhilfe zu geben aber auf
bilateraler Basis kein Vito keine
Erpressung doch wenn jeder einzeln hilft
wird die Ukraine Hilfe wohl teurer kommt
später zu dem lehnt Ungarn eine
Mindeststeuer für Weltkonzerne ab und
beides soll nicht zu tun haben mit dem
Streit um den Rechtsstaat
die Justiz sind Ungarn ist nicht
unabhängig das Geld aus Brüssel ist
nicht gegen Missbrauch geschützt diese
Einschätzung der EU-Kommission steht
gegen das Nein von Ungarn auf anderen
Feldern die Verbindung ist also doch ein
Hebel auch umgekehrt die Ungarn haben es
verbunden und jetzt muss klar sein
solange es diese vetus gibt können die
Gelder auf gar keinen Fall ausbezahlt
werden kann auch der der Corona
Wiederaufbauplan nicht freigegeben
werden Orban sitzt eigentlich am
kürzeren Hebel auf Druck aus dem
Berliner Kanzleramt so heißt es in
Brüssel gibt es nun aber eine zweite
Einschätzung ob Ungarn durch Reformen
wieder ein Rechtsstaat wird das Ergebnis
wäre die Stellschraube das Gipfel Thema
nächste Woche am selben Ort in höherer
Besetzung
das wollen wir noch vertiefen mit
unserem europakausponenten Ulf Fröhler
und wie wie kann man das nennen was
Orban da versucht ist das eine Art
Erpressung
ja ich glaube das kann man schon einer
Erpressung nennen ich glaube selbst
urban würde sagen er will es wissen er
glaubt dass er sehr sehr stark ist weil
er eben einige wichtige Entscheidungen
blockiert er hat im früheren Jahren
zurückgezogen aber diesmal tut er das
nicht und daran ist eben zu sehen wie
Schicksal auf diese Entscheidung es geht
um nicht weniger als wenn Orban sich
durchsetzt das Rechtsstaatlichkeit eben
nicht mehr die Rolle in der Europäischen
Union spielt und auch der Kampf gegen
Korruption und deshalb hat ja die
Kommission sehr lange darüber
nachgedacht und die Empfehlung
ausgegeben eben Orban nicht das Geld zu
geben um ein Zeichen zu setzen um so
fataler jetzt das gerade Länder wie
Frankreich und auch Deutschland sagen
wir müssen noch mals prüfen obwohl viel
geprüft worden ist bei Orban aber sie
versuchen so vielleicht noch ein
Kompromiss hinzukriegen ein gefährliches
Spiel das das wäre jetzt auch die
Nachfrage sind sich denn die anderen 26
überhaupt so einig also jetzt bei der
Ukraine Sache ja wir haben es eben
gehört alle sind frustriert
aber wenn man mal an die Vergangenheit
denkt da fand Orban eigentlich zumindest
zum Beispiel mit den Polen oder
Tschechen ja eine Interessengemeinschaft
Unterstützung
ich glaube das ist auch ein Grund warum
Frankreich und Deutschland noch mal auf
ein Versuch unternehmen um das Problem
zu lösen um ein Kompromiss zu finden um
Orban die Gelder zu sperren braucht es
eigentlich eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit im
Europäischen Rat und die ist absolut
nicht sicher viele Länder gerade im Süd-
und Osteuropa haben Angst wenn solche
Korruptionsverfahren durchgeführt werden
von der Europäischen Union dass sie dann
selber vielleicht Probleme kriegen und
keine Gelder kriegen deshalb ist diese
Mehrheit nicht gesichert und damit
spielt eben auch aber und das versucht
jetzt Frankreich und Deutschland
irgendwie zu umgehen damit es eben nicht
zu diesem Showdown kommt weil dann würde
man vielleicht erkennen dass diese
werteunion von der Europa immer spricht
eben gar nicht so existiert
das zeigt Orban ja auch in Dilemma mit
Blick auf den Westbalkan also wir
schalten dich ja aus aus Tirana von dem
westbalkan-gipfel Erweitern einerseits
geostrategisch vermutlich sinnvoll aber
andererseits hat man dann eben ja auch
sich Probleme ins Haus geholt
ja das ist eigentlich ein Dilemma was
man an Orban sehen kann und man kann das
eben dann auch hier am Westbalkan sehen
es ist ganz wichtig diese Länder
stärkeren Europäische Union zu binden
die Idee dass man den Einfluss von
Russland und China die sehr stark in
diesen Ländern werden eben zurückdrängen
will aber wenn man sie wirklich an
Europa binden will muss man ihn eine
Perspektive geben beizutreten und
eigentlich erfüllen keine dieser sechs
Länder bisher die Kriterien
wahrscheinlich auf Jahre nicht und nun
muss man entscheiden was man macht ein
klassischen politischen Kompromiss wenn
man sie reinholt wie gesagt dann holt
man sich auch Probleme rein auch hier
eine Lämmer es sind historische Zeiten
auch in Europa danke schön für die
Analyse
und mit Russlands Krieg gegen die
Ukraine und welche neuen Entwicklungen
ist da gibt da geht's jetzt bei dir
weiter Heinz der chemische Putin hat
heute den Sicherheitsrat seines Landes
einberufen nach mehreren
Drohnenangriffen auf russischem
Militärstützpunkte die Regierung in
Moskau macht dafür die Ukraine
verantwortlich angegriffen wurden
demnach gestern die
Luftwaffenstützpunkte Engels und ja
gilevo die mehrere hundert Kilometer von
der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt liegen
heute ein Feuer auf einem Flugplatz in
der südwestrussischen Region Kursk die
ukrainische Regierung äußerte sich
zunächst nicht direkt dazu
zwei Unternehmen des früheren
US-Präsidenten Donald Trump sind in
einem Prozess in New York unter anderem
wegen Steuerbetrugs schuldig gesprochen
worden eine Jury sah die Unternehmen in
allen 17 Anklagepunkten als schuldig an
wieder oberste Staatsanwalt von
Manhattan mithaltet das Strafmaß soll am
13 Januar verkündet werden Ex-Präsident
Trump war nicht persönlich angeklagt
als erste Bundesländer schaffen Bayern
und Sachsen-Anhalt die maskenpflicht im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr ab Maske tragen
ist in Bussen und Bahnen in
Sachsen-Anhalt ab Donnerstag und in
Bayern ab Samstag nur noch eine
Empfehlung denn die corona-lage sei
stabil so die Landesregierungen
stattdessen appellierten sie an die
Eigenverantwortung der Menschen das
Robert Koch-Institut ist gegen eine
Lockerung der maskenregeln
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
entschieden dass eine Beteiligung
Deutschlands am sogenannten
corona-hilfsfonds der EU rechtens ist
die EU habe weder ihre Kompetenzen
überschritten noch sei die
haushaltspolitische Verantwortung des
Bundestages beeinträchtigt erklärte das
Gericht zu zwei Verfassungsbeschwerden
für den EU Wiederaufbau kann die
EU-Kommission bis zu 750 Milliarden Euro
am Kapitalmarkt aufnehmen
nach der Messe Attacke auf zwei
Schülerinnen gestern in
Iller Kirchberg bei Ulm ist gegen den
Tatverdächtigen aus Eritrea Haftbefehl
wegen Mordes und versuchten Mordes
erlassen worden eine 14-Jährige war an
Stichverletzungen gestorben eine
13-Jährige wurde schwer verletzt so
Motiv gibt es bislang keine Erkenntnisse
der Verdächtige hat gegenüber der
Richterin keine Angaben zur Tat gemacht
die Betreiber einer darknet-plattform
die Aufnahmen schwerster sexualisierter
Gewalt an Kindern zeigte sind vom
Landgericht Frankfurt am Main zu
Haftstrafen verurteilt worden zwei
Männer müssen für 12 und 10,5 Jahre ins
Gefängnis mit anschließender
Sicherungsverwahrung auch weil sie
selbst Kinder sexuell missbrauchten zwei
weitere Angeklagte wurden zu sieben und
acht Jahren Haft verurteilt die
Plattform Boys town hatte weltweit mehr
als 400.000 Benutzerkonten
einen deutschen Täter aus diesem
Netzwerk hatten die Ermittler sogar bis
in eine Waldhütte in Paraguay verfolgt
und dort festgenommen ein Signal wir
kriegen euch egal wo ihr steckt
davon immer ist gelingt Missbrauchsfälle
aufzuklären ist es zugleich jedes Mal
wieder erschütternd welches Ausmaß die
Taten hatten wie viele Kinder betroffen
waren und wie lange Täter unentdeckt
blieben wie im Fall Wermelskirchen bei
dem heute Prozessauftakt war der
Angeklagte soll über viele Jahre Kindern
schwerste sexualisierte Gewalt angetan
haben manche Opfer waren noch ein Baby
Alter schon den Prozess heute zu
verfolgen war kaum erträglich dort
Färber berichtet
ein Monster vielleicht sah die
Bezeichnung für den Angeklagten gar
nicht so falsch sagt dessen eigener
Verteidiger zwei Stunden lang wird heute
in Köln die Anklageschrift verlesen der
Saal voller Anwälte Betroffener Familien
dem Beschuldigten hatten sie als
Babysitter vertraut er missbraucht ihre
Kinder auf brutalste Art Jahre lang
einige waren erst wenige Monate alt
andere hatten Behinderungen
es ist nicht nachvollziehbar so das
Schlimmste was man sich vorstellen kann
also in jeglicher Vorstellung die man
hat wo man denkt was Menschen einem
antun können kommt man gar nicht auf
solche Gedanken was der Angeklagte mit
den Kindern gemacht hat in diesem
Wohngebiet in der Nähe von Köln wurde
der 45-Jährige vor einem Jahr
festgenommen ein verheirateter Mann ohne
Vorstrafen der als IT-Experte arbeitete
anderthalb Millionen Videos und
dreieinhalb Millionen Fotos von
missbrauchsdarstellungen fand die
Polizei bei ihm seine eigenen Taten und
die andere nach seiner Festnahme
kooperierte er mit der Polizei er hat
weitgehend versucht bei Chat Kontakten
aus dieser Szene zu identifizieren wer
der jeweilige Gesprächspartner auf der
anderen Seite ist
er hat geholfen zu identifizieren wer
teilweise auf Videos sogar dokumentiert
mit der Mitarbeiter ist eine besondere
Ermittlungsgruppe bei der Polizei Köln
hat so inzwischen mehr als 130
Beschuldigte ausfindig gemacht der
Prozess heute der Auftakt es dürften
noch viele weitere kommen in
verschiedenen Bundesländern
Täter die dem anderen live bei der
Vergewaltigung von Kleinkindern zu sahen
sich wechselseitig ermunterten wieder
Angeklagte in Köln nach der
Anklageschrift geht die
Staatsanwaltschaft auch davon aus dass
der Angeklagte für die Allgemeinheit
gefährlich ist sie hatte deswegen seine
Unterbringung in der
Sicherungsverwahrung beantragt auch
deswegen wird er angeklagt in diesem
Verfahren psychiatrisch begutachtet als
Babysitter mit guten Referenzen hatte
der Angeklagte das Vertrauen der Eltern
erworben einige Kinder konnten noch
nicht sprechen anderen gab es Schlaf und
Betäubungsmittel die Familien ernten bis
zuletzt nichts von den Taten eine
betroffene Mutter erhofft sich
Aufklärung sie hat sich natürlich enorme
Vorwürfe hätte ich das nicht verhindern
können wie konnte ich dieses wie er sich
selbst ja bezeichnen Monster in unsere
Wohnung lassen und das ist das brutale
hier ein ganz perfides Vorgehen die
Vorwürfe hat der Angeklagte zum
Prozessbeginn gleich eingeräumt die
Beweise durch die Bilder sind auch
erdrückend dennoch sind mehr als 20
Verhandlungstage vorgesehen um das
Unvorstellbare besser zu verstehen
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit ganz
anderen Themen
die weltweite Energiekrise führt nach
einer neuen Studie der Internationalen
Energieagentur dazu dass der Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien deutlich schneller
vorankommt weil er realer wo erwartet
die Agentur den stärksten Umbau
tatsächlich traut in Europa die
Energieagentur Deutschland am meisten zu
also den mit Abstand größten Ausbau
grüne Energie weltweit ist das laut der
Prognose China das Land ist schon länger
weltweit der größte Investor für grüne
Energie wobei es gleichzeitig weiter
Kohlekraftwerke baut und dadurch auch
sein CO2-Ausstoß weiter erstmal steigern
wird insgesamt aber ist der Ausbau
grüner Energie ein globaler Trend der
sich auch in Europa den USA und Indien
stark beschleunigen wird die
Energieagentur rechnet sogar mit einem
regelrechten Boom demnach wird sich
grüner Strom in den kommenden fünf
Jahren sogar verdoppeln und Kohle als
größten Strom Erzeuger ablösen Größe des
Ausbaupotential Fall soll dabei die
Sonnenenergie haben weil große
Solarparks in vielen Ländern nach wie
vor die günstigste Stromquelle sein
bislang war vor allem Klimaschutz die
Motivation jetzt ist es eher
Versorgungssicherheit die Energiekrise
ausgelöst durch den Ukraine Krieg bewegt
viele Regierungen dazu grünen Strom im
eigenen Land zu forcieren sie wollen
einfach unabhängiger werden von
Energieimporten die Energieagentur hält
das nicht für ein vorübergehendes
Phänomen sie spricht sogar von einem
historischen Wendepunkt
vielen Dank
in der EU soll die Einfuhr von
bestimmten Produkten verboten werden
wenn dafür seit 2021 Wald abgeholzt
wurde auf einen entsprechenden
Gesetzentwurf haben sich die
Unterhändler des Europaparlaments und
der EU-Mitgliedsstaaten geeinigt
Konsequenzen haben wir dies für
Rohstoffe wie Fleisch Kakao oder Soja
aber auch für waren in denen solche
Rohstoffe enthalten sind e Parlament und
die Mitgliedstaaten müssen dem Gesetz
noch zustimmen
mit der Komödie guck mal wer da spricht
feierte sie 1989 ihren größten
Kinoerfolg nun ist die US-Schauspielerin
kirstyley gestorben bekannt war sie auch
für ihre Rolle in der Comedy-Serie
cheers dafür wurde sie mit einem Golden
Globe und einem Emmy ausgezeichnet
Krebserkrankung im Alter von 71 Jahren
zur Fußball-WM heute die beiden letzten
achtelfinalpartien da besiegte Portugal
die Schweiz souverän mit 6:1 zuvor
sorgte Marokko für eine Überraschung mit
einem Sieg gegen Ex-Weltmeister Spanien
nach torlosen 120 Minuten gewannen die
Nordafrikaner das Elfmeterschießen mit
drei zu null und wurden auf dem Fanfest
in Doha von begeisterten Zuschauern
gefeiert
der Wahl der Deutsche Fußball-Bund mit
der Aufarbeitung kämpft einer ist ja
bereits vom Platz gegangen Oliver
Bierhoff gerade noch rechtzeitig vor dem
großen dfb-gipfel morgen das mindestens
einer aus der Führungsriege der
Nationalmannschaft gehen muss stand im
Raum also besser man geht bevor man
gegangen wird welche Reaktion ist darauf
gibt und welche Erwartungen sich auf das
Krisentreffen morgen berichten berichtet
Hermann
so werden die Fußballfans Oliver
Bierhoff nicht mehr erleben sein schon
nachdenklich wirkender Abgang nach dem
peinlichen WM Vorrunden aus der
deutschen Nationalelf tatsächlich eine
seiner letzten Amtshandlungen beim
Deutschen Fußballbund
einige Entscheidungen von denen wir
überzeugt waren haben sich nicht als die
richtigen erwiesen das bedeutet niemand
mehr als ich dafür übernehme ich die
Verantwortung
unrühmliches Ende der 2004 beginnenden
Ära die geprägtes von Aufbruchstimmung
vom WM Triumph 2014 von großen Erfolgen
sportlich wie marketingtechnisch 18
Jahre in denen der viel gepriesenen
Mannschaft erst die Bodenhaftung und
dann das Spiel Glück verloren gehen die
drei Turniere Anhalten der
Erfolglosigkeit das mit DFB-Präsident
Neuendorf zu verantworten der
kommunikationsdesaster um die One Love
Armbinde und die Wahl des erneut weit
entrückten Mannschaftsquartier sind im
dfb-direktor zum Verhängnis geworden
Oliver Bierhoff hat sich große Verdienst
um den DFB erworben auch wenn die
letzten Turniere hinter den sportlichen
Zielen zurückblieben steht er für große
Momente er war einer der hat viel
vorangetrieben auch mit der neuen
Akademie also ich finde es sehr traurig
weil ich ihm viel zu verdanken habe
persönlich sehe ich auch als die
richtigen Entscheidungen weil man muss
vieles überdenken man muss neue
Strukturen schaffen deswegen finde ich
es auch gut der personelle
Veränderungsbedarf beim DFB könnte sich
womöglich ausweiten Bundestrainer haben
sie Flick der morgen zum Rapport
bestellt ist in die DFB-Zentrale
reagiert betroffen
meinem Trainerteam und mir fällt im
Moment die vorstellungs schwer wie die
durch Olivers Ausscheiden entstehende
Lücke fachlich und menschlich
geschlossen werden kann
Flick verliert eine Vertrauensperson
einen Fachmann und Wegbegleiter das gilt
es zusätzlich zum bitteren Ende aller WM
Hoffnungen zu verkraften und der
Bundestrainer hat nicht zuletzt mit
seinem vorzeitigen Abgang bei den Bayern
gezeigt dass er schneller servus sagt
als man denkt wenn er keine
Vertrauensbasis spürt
das war es von uns gleich im Anschluss
geht es bei Markus Lanz weiter und wir
melden uns dann morgen wieder dann
morgen zur gewohnten Zeit auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Sommer ist
vorbei und es gibt eine Auswertung über
die hochladen in den zentral und
Ostalpen jeder dieser Balken ist ein
Sommer und das seit 1901 und wenn wir
uns für diese Grafik hier anschauen sind
Sie hier den letzten beiden ihr dazu
gekommen ist es das Jahr 2022 überragt
alle anderen es war also die wärmste
Zeit in diesem Sommer und das hat er
Auswirkungen z.B am Alex Gletscher in
der Schweiz sechs Meter von diesem
Gletscher fehlen sie sehen hier diese
Stange hier die sechs Meter hoch und
hier das ist Matthias Huss der diese
Messung anstellt schauen wir auf das
aktuelle Wetter unterbekommen wir von
Norden der Kaltluft allerdings ist die
nicht ganz so kalt aber feucht und
bringt Schauer auch in der kommenden
Nacht in der Nordhälfte kommt Regen und
Schnee auf der sich südostwärts
verlagert
Südwesten ist es trockenteils bildet
sich Nebel und es wird glatt der die
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf -1 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und -3 Grad zum
Beispiel an den alpenfrostfrei nach
Nordwesten hin bei +3 Grad an der
Nordsee morgen dann weitere Schauer die
sich südostwärts verbreiten ja und hier
vor allem im Erzgebirge stauen da kann
es länger schneiden ansonsten im
Südwesten sonniger Abschnitte bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 0 bis 6 Grad
Schauer gibt es auch in den nächsten
Tagen auch in Form von Schnee am
Donnerstag zum Beispiel bei -1-5 Grad ja
und danach wird es allmählich kälter
unserem am Samstag gibt's im Süden
kräftigen Schneefall ein schöner Abend